but I want to talk about something more
important that you're the kind of guy
who sits down and read the paragraph out
of a book yeah yeah and that pisses me
off cause you were boring me already no
no sat down yeah and he literally opened
a book and starts reading and I was like
I just ought to be here in two seconds
what are you trying to get done though
no no I reiterated a you get ready for
his job and on yeah but now whatever
that is pisses me off I feel my brain
pan and I like to I like to get those
thoughts out to other people as well ok
so you my fan base so well your mental
workout so what you're doing is you're
finding something so you can share it
with the podcast right yeah okay yeah
the people they could just look it up no
don't know what you I go by the book oh
yeah thought about not enough kid kind
book of the week baby yeah you didn't do
[ __ ] now listen me you just recite hey
we can't regurgitate ya book you like a
mama bird no regurgitating Emma for both
you need to know something and the fan
base is the baby birds and you Jeff my
mama's burger mama bird open your a open
your [ __ ] mouth baby birds it will do
that so we agreed don't do the dropping
no you don't come into my podcast and so
rearranging your economy you make money
talking about wanting to be a [ __ ]
Russian spy or whatever god no is my dog
I don't I'm going stuffed now you don't
need to so don't have a bit called
dropping knowledge so much of a bit
about how you want to save a girl from
[ __ ] the guys from taken yeah well
they don't have a bit called drop don't
pause when you say it just say dropping
mountains all right I eight royale this
morning or almost rolling and all the
lot of you i have a light energy leave
me a lot of videos that we will dude a
lot of it you take terrible video don't
say anything the one of your restaurant
I usually never hit up oh my god each
other like I gotta jump into now erase
it after you guys told me that dude cry
well cuz its [ __ ] be on Coney it's my
boys right I'm sure the restaurant is
great amazing but take a better video
nothing I need solo I real
I realize that the video love Sarah
light literally like and y'all together
a lot of music yeah and it's not good
man y'all me a break delicious spaghetti
the god damn it when you said that when
i get a text he just said hey this video
makes me really want to go to the rest
off you go sure does my ring I got
subconscious immediately soon I it was
late though I don't you trying to do
right but I watched and I was like well
this is the worst video this year
literally the lowest budget I would
never go to that restaurant now what's
left for Dana to do sold the UFC for
four billion dollars he's the pioneer of
MMA he's this business man and now he
put together the biggest paper paper
view of all time we all be Dana's eagle
in the sport he loves boxing don't act
like Dana White doesn't want to be in
the box it happened yeah that's
happening yeah you know if they never
got to the UFC and had a non-compete my
prediction but I really think he would
go into the music business I think he
was musing promoting fights is his love
of music and really all what kind of
music he loves it all man for rent he
loves dirty metal head bang really thin
mosh pits before be caught on camera guy
people don't know he comes into the
arena on show day and makes them play
everybody's walkout song and then he
will tell them a little more bass a
little less travel yet he's our host cut
to walk off some yo-yo kind of lately he
do that to me before brazil call me
can't come out to that too boring no do
he goes to friendly yeah okay i I came
out to a song he called me do the same
thing and but I mean he is a sound guy
he fancies himself as that he is that so
I mean his true passions yeah he got
them away i guess he loves it but to act
like he loves it more than boxing i
don't know if that I mean I guess we'd
have to ask him but I think he would
like to do boxing I guess that's what
I'm saying that's why I really think
he'd have fun I feel like and maybe it's
in the meeting you can see him now now
that he sold he's met kind of he climbed
Everest he put his fake up there four
billion dollars I feel like he's a
little more relaxed easygoing now yeah i
doctored i say i think that that would
be a psychology i mean he's got to just
be really happy you know he's getting
really not be a happy guy he said
seated he set a goal and he made it and
yet let's see where that all goes you
know you do hear talk about how long
will Dana be then I think its contracts
only four five years I just think if
it's a stock and you take Dana White out
of it man you short that stock that that
is a brain that knows how to manage and
and round up cat fighters are not the
easiest guys to work no we've got to get
big and strong at times with them it's
the only way to do it now look look look
I'm it'd be like me trying out like
really really doing football drills all
the time lifting weights and taking
storage and trying out the NFL every
Saturday Goodman and I'm gonna get it
this year I'm getting this here I just
can't my 40 still at 49 hey guys all
right yes and I just be sure I'd be
routed to the gills I'd be a bloody
[ __ ] purple blood pressure through
the roof sweating all the time this is
the year guys this is the year dude
let's say what's interesting is my girls
uh grandma staying with us speaks zero
English zero after you don't understand
nothing so my girl was a translator and
we're put the baby to bed we're all
sitting down I make tea every night 19
[ __ ] tea every night and I asked her
she want tea and on the Casa Grande she
wants teen she's like she goes like this
like it was p I didn't ask if you want
[ __ ] coke just [ __ ] poison Jesus
Christ and so I'm like what's her deal
with tea well she she she bad
association well yeah I grew up in
Mexico dirt-poor they would go around
and didn't have any money and they'd
sleep in a basic a one-bedroom guy
taught thing and there's six kids and
they'd sleep in there and they can't
afford like flavored drinks or anything
so her mom they gather round they'd make
a fire and this little tot and she would
have her steal like leaves or orange
peels out of trash and then they would
make tea out of a used orange peels it
would be like orange tea at night for
vitamin C well no just four flavors and
regional excuse me see that's that rich
white boy [ __ ] yeah I think
to pour that thing family I didn't give
a [ __ ] about life's want it easily ya
know they just how about that poverty
how about that how about that what that
does to you once you say like oh my god
yeah now now think about how that makes
sense we don't want to well there's that
poverty we're like in Afghanistan they
were the Russian this Russian guy was
talking about in 1979 he would go into a
hut and they had a Quran in the corner
and nothing else nothing else and he was
like where are you sleeping how are you
living and because of the warm because
just too dire poverty that's how a lot
of people is crazy yeah don't want my
story with us no it's the same ideal I'm
done it's the same idea you human beings
is real so find solace in just some
orange peel [ __ ] yeah and there's such a
tight-knit families because when you
think about it's all the hat is family
that they have no money there's no
material thing sold family that's why
they speak so close together